ليله عصيبه جدا مرت على العاصمه كيف
مواطني كيف يمكن ان نقول انهم لم يناموا
الليل بسبب هذه الهجمات 35 طائره مسيره
اطلقت نحو جميع ومعظم احياء هذه المدينه
تم اسقاط الخمسه وثلاثين طائره جميعهم لم
تسجل اصابات كبيره ولكن طبعا يعني كان
هناك خسائر في بعض السيارات التي كانت في
الشوارع في بعض الساحات في بعض الكراجات
وكذلك
عدد من المصابين الذين نقلوا الى
المستشفيات الوضع في اكييف بخصوص المصابين
هو اقل طبعا من بقيه الولايات التي
استهدفت بضربات صاروخيه 16 ضربه صاروخيه
استهدفت خاركيف وخرسون
حتى الان ايضا لا يوجد قتله ولكن هنالك
ايضا عدد من المصابين الذين نقلوا الى
المستشفيات بعضهم في حاله حرجه تم ايضا
تسجيل 61 ضربه
جويه وكذلك تم تسجيل ضربات براجمات
الصواريخ
وايضا تم سد 55 هجوما في الجبهات القتال
المختلفه الحديث عن مخموت وافديفكا
ومارينكا وكذلك في اتجاه الايمان الوضع في
الشرق الاوكراني تحديدا في مدينه ابوخموت
السلطات ان القوات الاوكرانيه مازالت
تدافع وتدافع بشراسه تحاول القوات الروسيه
التقدم لاكمال سيطرتها على هذه المدينه
قائد القوات البريه الاوكرانيه يقول انهم
مطمئنون لوضعات دفاعات في المدينه وكذلك
طبعا تعلم خالد ان القوات الاوكرانيه منذ
فتره بعد ان احست بالضغط الكبير من قبل
القوات الروسيه بدات في تجهيز دفاعاتها
الهندسيه غرب المدينه حتى تمنع التقدم حتى
وان اضطرت الى الانسحاب رويدا الرويدا حتى
تمنع التقدم بشكل ممنهج ومستمر نحو مدينه
كرامه لذلك هم مطمئنون الان لهذه الدفاعات
الهندسيه كذلك طبعا كان هنالك ضربات
الصواريخ في اتجاه شاسا فيار
لا يمكن كما قال العمده انه عمليه الاجلاء
للمدنيين اصبحت شبه مستحيله بالسيارات لا
يمكن التحرك هم يخرجون على ارجلهم الان
تفعل السلطات المستحيل لاجلاء المدنيين من
هذه المدينه هذه المدينه هم في انها اصبحت
شبه مركز استراتيجي للقوات الاوكرانيه
التي منها تتقدم
يتقدم الدعم نحو جبهه محمود بهذا الطريقه
الاستراتيجي وكذلك ايضا قامت الفرق
الهندسيه بشكل طرق اخرى في الطرق يعني في
الغابات طرق جديده للدخول الى جبهه بخبوط
بعد ان استعصى واصبح من الصعب الدخول فقط
عن طريق الطريقه الاستراتيجي ضخمه لانه
اصبح في مرمى نيران المدفعيه الروسيه
الوضع الان في كيف تم الغاء اغاره جويه
قبل قليل طبعا حاله التاهب الجوي الان
الوضع هادي ولكن هنالك قلق كبير جدا وسط
المدنيين وسط المواطنين مما يمكن ان يحدث
في هذه الليله طبعا ليله التاسع من مايو
او ما يمكن ان يحدث غدا ولكن طبعا وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه نائبه وزير الدفاع ان
مولر قالت انه قد يحدث هجوم وقد لا يحدث
هجوم هذا الامر
قد يحدث او لا يحدث لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات